I have to confess up front that my
children are older than yours I have two
kids
and my daughter is now 19 and my son is
about to be 17 but it became a thing in
our family
uh a couple of years ago to watch the
original Gossip Girl you're a Gossip
Girl and we would we would watch it and
it became our ritual and
um the kids you know because they were
too young when it originally happened
and so we all kind of bonded over
watching it together and then I would
freak Sona out because here I am a man
well into my 80s and and I would be at
work and I would be talking about the
plot line I've gone through and I know
all the names yeah that's really
surprising and I know all this stuff and
you would say Conan it's it's like it's
creepy that you know so much about
what's happening his uh TV knowledge is
1970s cop dramas and Gossip Girl that's
it that is really uh yeah okay all right
I'm gonna tell you something I'm going
to tell you something it holds up it
holds up but that's good to hear uh it
holds up and uh you have moved on and uh
have I yeah
yeah sure yes you have I have certain
obsessions which is the breakfast you
guys have on that show right the other
waffles the waffles and um and you know
Rufus uh is your your dad is always
making what looks to be like a a
seventeen hundred dollar Four Seasons
breakfast you guys each take one little
bite and then say I gotta go and leave
every you're right every single time
every single time and I'm looking at all
this untouched I mean beautiful golden
brown Belgian waffles giant piles of
strawberries giant pictures of freshly
squeezed orange juice yeah and um one
man one man did that one man did that
and he gave up his music career to do it
but also clearly our uh and this ties
into what I want to talk about
later on in the conversation uh which is
uh your podcast which I've been really
enjoying and
um pod crash and when pun crushed pod
crushed sorry
um your podcast pod crushed which
one of the things that you talk about is
people in uh who are experiencing
middle school and being awkward and and
and having all this anxiety and all of
us felt a lot of that at that age and
it's really good to get the word out
that that's how it is and yet you first
came to fame as part of this show that
was you know uh showing people this
really uh the most super confident I
mean which is not permit for for for for
that no one had acne no well because
because we were all in our 20s
I still had acne in my 20s I don't know
what your problem is I had uh acne
Durant up until uh Obama's second term
but no but one of the things that uh uh
what I watch now and it's and clearly
the show placed almost the camp of it is
I love watching
um
uh Chuck Bass
the Chuck Bass character he's literally
calling people you know there's like a
fireplace behind him and he's wearing a
smoking jacket yeah like he's like he's
60 years old yeah and he's telling
people I've got controlling interests of
krill Co Industries I bought out your
shares you're through see yourself out
don't let the door hit through the ass
he's 15. and he's got a PSAT tomorrow
and I've always I love it I can't get
enough of it I just love all of it I I
really like this perspective I need this
perspective well you know it's really
great because your character is the sort
of dose of reality you're constantly
looking around saying this is in in in
many ways that's that's true that's true
now this is the thing that I grappled
with a lot when I was on the show and I
was clear with it about the writers and
I was I was you know it was open
conversation I guess
uh the the thing about Dan Humphrey that
it seems is that is that the whole point
of the show is that it discovered that
it's
the the joy of the experience was that
it wasn't worried about
the real world it wasn't it wasn't
worried about the moral Center so Dan
became kind of like
well he became Gossip Girl this is
really what he had to become spoil alert
yeah I'm sorry sorry
um but uh no it's uh it is still
um I just
it's it's really fun to watch and I
remember because I was living in New
York at the time what a big deal it was
when you guys would be shooting on the
street
and of course I was too old
um had I been hanging out trying to see
one of you come out of a trailer I'd
have been arrested uh and rightfully so
um but it was such a big deal it was
such a uh and it's now it's this
document of this cultural moment but I
do think the show has a sense of humor
about itself clearly absolutely you know
they're clearly uh enjoying the fact
that no
it's all what we wish we could have been
at that age including those of us on the
show yeah yeah exactly no it's true yeah
yeah it's it's completely aspirational
in that sense that
yeah it's fantasy the first time that I
ran across that was 90210 when that was
coming along in the 80s and it was such
a big deal and I remembered thinking I
know why this is so appealing to
everybody it's all what we wish High
School could have been in some ways do
you know what I mean I wish if I had if
I knew
then what I know now if I knew how to
talk to someone of the opposite sex if I
had a credit card if I had a decent car
maybe things would have been different
we all know that they wouldn't have been
they wouldn't have been
see this this is where you know I think
like
so as the there's there's levels to it
and so what you just described I think
makes it makes it it's the it's the
charm of it and then I think what I what
I grappled with during it was like also
you know what is the net effect
it can't be measured but what is the net
effect of of because it's just one it's
one drop in a in this in this bucket of
of Storytelling we've seen for the last
I don't know you know
50 years or something about
you know like glamorized glorified youth
yeah and and it and it and actually I
mean I'm actually I'm not I don't I
don't feel like I'm here to really
promote my podcast I feel silly but I do
have one and that and that is what that
is what we talk about but I've been
listening to I've been listening to your
podcast and I and it occurred to me that
there is a it fascinates me there is a
connection to
um you know some of the work that you
were doing you know just getting started
in your career which is something that
is
uh part it is almost a whole sub-genre
of entertainment which is we're going to
present
uh 17 year olds who go to high school or
18 year olds and we're going to show
them in this way that we all kind of
wish we could have been you know but or
want to be currently if you're like in
the writer's room and you're maybe 35
and you're because really that is the
like the way they all behave emotionally
in relationship it's far closer to that
of like a 30-something or a late 20s you
know in New York and or L.A you know
it's that it really is I think the sort
of fantasy behavior of how
of how adults want to be you know if you
saw actual 15 and 16 year olds cast in
these roles you'd be horrified yeah you
really would be horrified well it would
be so funny because there'd be a real 15
year old with
um cystic acne who's playing Chuck Bass
going you're through social
exactly and he's vomiting from the
scotches yeah
This Is Us burning my throat
you're through it Basco what are you
doing up mother yeah I'm trying to fire
the shareholder go to bed I'm sorry he
doesn't have any shares in your company
he's not old enough you still have the
company don't say that
you know it's funny like it'll be
they'll be what you just pitched is a to
me a really funny sketch
of Gossip Girl played by uh actual
actual 14 and 15 year olds that shot
single camera and
um you know people making these moves
like I'm off to Paris no you're not
you're not you're going to Paris you're
going to go to you're going to go to
high school yeah by the way don't you
have a paper due tomorrow I'm on the
trail of a killer no you're not
that's right on the trail of an actual
killer yeah when the FBI's work yes yes
they always have a scheme yeah and it's
always like uh you know okay here's the
plan we're all gonna go to uh we're all
gonna go to stad we're taking a private
plane to start and we're gonna stop them
from stealing I don't know I I'm always
I'll have to quote but I don't really
know where it ishtad in Switzerland I
think it's interesting I have no idea
anyway use it as you're like it's a
go-to yeah someday I want to have I want
to have some money nestled away in stock
but anyway it is it is Switzerland it
just really uh
that's a really funny idea is
um is is we'll get together and we'll
produce that because actually really
awkward uh kids and constantly their
parents intervening and saying no you're
not a shareholder you don't you know you
have no no get get back into your room
and finish no you can't that's not gonna
happen yeah and and I actually think
like the the quote-unquote love scenes
like the the real awkwardness of of two
15 year olds kind of like barely being
able to look at each other and just you
know having having I mean think about
that think about the emotional maturity
15 16 17 year old in a relationship I
mean you think about the way that like
we would hold each other's faces and
look longingly and say things like I've
never you know just like just something
that's meant to be quite vulnerable yeah
and you think of like the way a real
teenager would do that oh
I still have never held anyone's face
I've been married 20 years and if I if I
put my hands on my wife's face
I think she'd call the police
you know what I mean and looked into her
eyes she'll be like why are you looking
at me I feel like if you were cast in
one of these high school shows it would
be actually more accurate I could do it
now now now at 59 I if you cast me as a
19 year old and Gossip Girl I think I
would be more convincing than 22 year
olds playing 19 year olds you know even
on that I would even say that there's no
you know there's no one who's okay just
just practically speaking the shot that
looks good from the side of two people
in love saying I love you you're so
close you actually can't see each other
you're out of focus one eye is here the
other eye is there and you're just like
and he was like okay
your action it's it's it's really absurd
so when you're bringing it to life you
never actually got a good look at Blake
live no no no I wouldn't recognize her
I can see that now and I'm gonna I'm
gonna look for that now when I go back
you seem uncertain about what you're am
I talking to a waffle or Blake Lively